so mr sinks as you mentioned the
pituitary stopped sending signals to
produce testosterone is there a natural
way to get your pituitary communicating
normally after trt that would be
hcg i would think wouldn't it be uh no
acg just sends the signal to your
testicles
so there's um naturally
you'll just have to wait it usually
takes about six months
maybe a year before everything kind of
picks up again so that's why we do post
cycle therapy
or you can call it post trt therapy yeah
um that's double therapy but it is what
it is
uh so you'll use fertility drugs to
restart the signaling process
you can use kisspeptin tin which has a
little bit of evidence that it's able to
um secrete the luteinizing hormone and
follicle stimulating hormone from the
pituitary
or you use a gonadotropin hormone
releasing hormone analog
like granadarellen tryptorelin bucyrelin
you have to dust at a low dose just
probably multiple times per day just to
send a little bit of signal
so now you're replacing the signal from
the hypothalamus to the pituitary
with three different drugs the gispeptin
10 works on the hypothalamus
to release release gonadotropin hormone
releasing hormone
but you can mimic this with one of the
fertility drugs
and then the last step from the
pituitary to the testicles is
luteinizing hormone follicle stimulating
hormone
which you can mimic with acg
or human menopausal gonadotropin which
contains
glutamatergic hormone and follicle
stimulating hormone
so you'll have to choose which of these
steps you want to
restart and
that's going to take time and not every
drug is as efficacious as the next guy
uh the next
drug so you'll have to figure out what
works so i've been running an experiment
with
kisspeptin 10 didn't work didn't raise
my allies in ephesians levels
and i'm still running it just to get the
blood work and then i probably have to
look at
another drug you can block the estrogen
receptor in the hypothalamus and
pituitary
with novadex climate and clomiphene
roloxephene
and send a little bit of signal that way
because there's always a negative
feedback
and of course when you're coming off trt
you're you're kind of in like this
hormonal imbalance limbo and and
selective estrogen receptor modulator
helps with that but it also acts as an
estrogen in the brain
so the clomid or anchlomaphine might
give you a little bit of side effects
you know estrogenic side effects in the
brain so you you watch titanic and then
suddenly
here's your starting really it's it's
insane like you think you're the most
alpha male
and you know all right you're successful
and you've accomplished a lot of things
and yeah and you're settled and you're
grounded
then you take kilometer and clomiphene
you start freaking crying during movies
yeah you know what's interesting a lot
of people um
think that when you start introducing
therapeutic doses of testosterone into
your
healthcare regime as you get older as a
guy like you're going to get more
aggressive you get more
like pissed off you know you get cut off
driving you know you're going to get
road rages but
for me i found it actually calm me like
you know having having
more balance levels of testosterone and
estrogen and all the other hormones
actually like stuff didn't bother me so
much yeah
no you because you're also actively
suppressing cortisol
if your testosterone is higher you
suppress your cortisol and that's also
one of those stress hormones that make
you a little bit agitated
yeah so if your testosterone is at the
top of the reference range a little bit
over
right wherever you feel comfortable and
your estrogen is the same
and it's nice and stable you feel very
grounded and leveled
yeah now you go and test trembling and
all this
bodybuilding stuff and higher dosages
yeah roid rates is definitely there and
you will feel pissed off while driving
i've been there many many times you know
driving in asia is uh
yes it's a one hell of a roller coaster
i would say yeah um
so it's it like there's a therapeutic
dose where you feel good
and then there's a too high of those
where you get good results but the side
effects start to manifest also
yeah that's like one of the questions my
doctor's always asking me is like you
know your
levels look good you're a little bit you
know higher under the reference range
you're getting pissed off
easily you know you get angry have any
anger issues i'm like no i feel really
good actually i feel very calm you know
nothing really gets under my skin
so no it just works better for me that
way i think for a lot of men if you
especially when you're older
even if you like when my testosterone
levels came back to about 600 nanograms
per deciliter
uh and now that i restarted again four
weeks
ago like quality of life improved
tremendously
just by having a little bit of
testosterone and pre-mobile in the mix
like i'm
a better sex drive a more outgoing more
uh
go-getter attitude regarding business
i'm able to work longer
right during the day so i can do well
six in the morning till 10 in the
evening if i wanted to
um right and i'm energetic throughout
the day which i didn't have
um when i was off trt
so there's there's there's huge benefits
what do you think about that
um sound bite that came off the
hubermann interview i think he was on
friedman's podcast
and he said something along the lines of
testosterone makes effort
feel good yeah it's very true it's it's
some sort of a dopaminergic or a
dopamine response in the brain
uh where you do something and you get
this little reward strategy or reward
and through a chemical uh release and it
it's certainly true
it's certainly true i mean your own
hormone replacement in the end of the
month when you're doing your financials
is a very rewarding
uh experience far more rewarding than
without the testosterone which is weird
to say um but yeah it's it
you're just more driven i would say more
driven
and and you're less um
less conflicted on how which direction
you need to go with uh business-wise
like if you're investing for example
sometimes there's a lot you have the
markets as this thing
and the news says this thing and then
you're not really sure
should i invest or not invest should i
sell or not sell
and then now that i'm four weeks back on
hormone replacement i know exactly what
to do
there's no conflict yeah it
clears up some of the brain fog you know
it's one of the things that people don't
understand is that
when you're deficient in testosterone
and one of the things that a lot of guys
get prescribed
incorrectly in my view is they get ssris
and antidepressants when they should
really be going on testosterone therapy
like a therapeutic dose of it not
nothing like bodybuilder levels but like
just just getting that that
level fixed and that fixes a problem for
most guys right
for sure for sure and and of course
there is a place for ssris but
most guys especially if your
testosterone levels are subclinical
that would be the immediate approach
going forward because our bodies works
on testosterone
and if your body is not not cooperating
producing sufficient amounts
supplement i mean women have been doing
that since the age of 15
with birth control so right we should be
able to do the same thing
and and in the end if you're more
productive
more business oriented um the whole
world benefits because the
economy is rolling that's that's the way
i look at it so
all right and then it's just a man a
matter of managing your health
accordingly which if you want to be a
bodybuilder it's
a constant sacrifice but with hormone
replacement therapy
even if it's a little bit plus the
management of health is is
is not that severe you can do your blood
work every three months
make a couple adjustments and and go
about your business
you